everyone this is kevin from the tennis
website comm and today we're looking at
game number four from the 2018 World
Chess Championships between the champion
Magnus Carlsen and his competitor
Fabiano Cara Juana the first three games
have all been drawls Fabiano's had the
white pieces in games one and three
Magnus Carlsen game number two as well
as today in game number four so we'll go
ahead and get into it with Magnus
Carlsen starting out with pawn to c4 and
this was a surprise I knew he would have
something different for this game he's
played Fabiano 37 times as far as
classical just normal time control not
blitz or rapid but just these longer
style games 37 times only played c4 1 so
not something Fabiano's used to seeing
from Magnus Carlsen we continue pawn to
e5 sort of the reverse Sicilian here
plays very different than normal
Sicilian but a lot of people will refer
to it as that Knight to c3 Knight f6
Knight f3 knight c6 getting into the
four Knights game of the English opening
always nice to see the English opening
played in London the fans did enjoy
seeing that so after pawn g3 Bishop down
here d5 we do see these pieces come off
the board these are the main lines but
after g2 we see something different the
main line from here would be just to
take down on c3 other options would be
to come back to c6 or could have just
played Bishop to e6 I think all those
are fine getting ready if you wanted to
castle on the Queen side but Fabiano
played it bishop down here to c5 it
didn't take long to play this seven
seconds as a matter of fact so he was
very prepared for this specific opening
now castle on the kingside Magnus if he
wanted to could have taken with his
knight Knight takes up here to e5 Knight
takes down c3 we could see the bishop
take a lot of just exchanging on the
board there's the double pawn here on
the C file after the pawn takes Queen
comes down here why
can no longer castle doesn't matter as
much once the Queen's come off the board
you can see Bishop comes down here takes
the pawn rook to f1 forcing the bishop
to come back here really just depends on
how much material both sides want to
exchange because you could have the rook
come up here it's protected by the
knight on e5 here Bishop to d6 forcing
the rook to come back because once the
knight moves the King could just take it
could see some material exchange right
here rook over here to e3 taking the
bishop because it's being pinned down to
the king
these players may not go down this
entire variation but this is definitely
going down a path where lots of material
is coming off the board Magnus Carlsen
not necessarily looking to do that so he
decides to just castle on the King side
Fabiano responds the same castle on the
King side pawn to d3 opening up for the
dark square bishop to get involved into
the game rook over here to e8 Bishop to
d2 as we talked about getting involved
and then the knight tag is here on c3 we
see the bishop take Knight to d4
so there's centralizing this piece in
the center of the board now this is
where things are interesting if you were
kind of following along listen to some
of the commentary you would notice that
Fabiana was playing blazing-fast every
move so far was under 10 seconds the
main reason is that he played this exact
same game move for move just a few
months ago against Wesley so with the
grand chess
tour in Paris now these players spend
countless days and months preparing for
this tournament they memorize every game
that they've played you know partly
their savants and that respect they can
play twenty five different people
blindfold they just have a mental
capacity to do that so they absolutely
know every game they've played a game
they've played a few months ago they
definitely remember and not only do they
remember but their opponents are
studying their opponents moves and all
of their games so not only does Fabiana
remember this but Magnus Carlsen knows
this game as well and so it really comes
to this position where you can really
expect Magnus Carlsen to do something he
knows exactly what's going on right here
they're both playing extremely fast in
that specific game we actually saw the
rook come to see one now that was a
blitz game so it was a little quicker
but it ended in a draw magnus carlsen
I'm sure looked at that he decides in
this position to instead play pawn to b4
so this is new new theory as far as this
line goes so the bishop comes back here
to d6 and then a rook to b1 now I have a
lot of options beside work to be won
some of the commentators felt that this
was going down really a path that Magnus
Carlsen can't lose but it's probably
gonna be more drawn than actually
winning other options if he wanted to be
a little bit more aggressive pawn to e5
err excuse me a4 or just pawn to e3
still gonna see the exchange here with
the Knights but just better as far as
giving more opportunities for attacking
lines but he decides to play rook to d1
Knight takes here bishop recaptures and
then pawn to a6 now white looking to
attack and expand on the Queen side
plays pawn to a4 black would really like
to get his light square Bishop involved
in so the game unfortunately can't move
it yet because it's the only piece
that's defending this pawn here on b7 so
first move in between decides to play
pawn to c6 just to stop the threat of
the bishop here on f3 rook over here to
e1 preparing to push this pawn forward
and then Bishop to d7 s we talked about
getting the bishop involved into the
game pawn to e3 Queen down here to f6
just trying to help control the center
of the board
it's behind two bishops so it wasn't
doing too much recognizing that needs to
try to control something in the middle
Bishop here to e4 and this is a pretty
good setup that Magnus Carlsen has he
has a very active board both of his
bishops in the center doing a lot more
than Fabiano the bishop back here on d7
not doing too much and this bishop here
on d6 really just playing defender not
really attacking
too much on the board so Fabiana decides
if he's in a situation she doesn't like
it's time to exchange material so Bishop
to f5 and we start to see some material
come off the board Queen f3 Bishop takes
Queen takes here on f6 pawn takes on f6
and then pawn recaptures on a4 so both
sides do have double pawns on the E and
the F file but they pretty much negates
each other's weakness out now pawn down
to b5 Magnus Carlsen has a few options
always think about this in your own
games he could decide to go ahead and
take he could push forward with a 5 if
he wants to always keep in mind that if
you're gonna play a 5 this all of a
sudden puts two pawns on dark squares
your opponent has a dark square Bishop
on the board so you don't want to be
putting as many pieces and pawns on dark
squares so magnus carlsen he's not
looking to do that right away first
plays rook to d1 attacking the bishop
bishops forced to move comes back here
to f8 and then we see the pawn take on
b5 so this you know they really ends up
being the same as far as material
standpoint but always looking for those
small things it was not going to haunt
him right away but later in the game as
we get to an in-game states both bishops
probably gonna be on the board you don't
want to have those pawns on dark squares
if you don't have to
so the pottery captures on b5 King to g2
getting it involved into the game rook
to d8 rook to c1 Magnus Carlsen not
quite yet looking to get straight down
to the endgame exchange off the rooks
King to g7 Bishop back here to e1 rook
c8 just defending this backward pawn
here on a c6 you know Magnus opened up
the door to attack that bring the bishop
down here to e1 now the rook on c1 is
able to attack that so it needs to
protect the backward pawn so rook to c8
now rook to c2 allowing for the other
rook to come to c1 and just double
barrel here we see rook down to a4 says
yeah if you want to move that rook
that's going to
cost you because now I'm gonna add an
attacker here yes the bishop is
defending it but black also has his own
[ __ ] appear on f8 attacking this pawn
on b4 now King to f3 just centralizing
the King pawn to h5 not much going on
the Queen side that black can really do
here so just decides to push up with
this pawn h5 King to e2 King a g6 pawn
h3 decides to go ahead and exchange
material in the center both sides no
longer have their double pawns on the E
and the F file pawn to f3 Bishop to e7
just gonna get more involved into the
game still want to stay on this long
dark diagonal to attack this pawn here
on b4 but this does open up the door if
he needs to come over and defend the
King side of the board he can pawn to e4
check King comes over here to e6 Bishop
to d2 bishop down here to d6 very
similar move as the one before rook to
c1 so says yeah I'm giving up this pawn
right here but I could just attack and
take this material here on c6 and then
from here the players decided to draw
it's only 34 moves in yeah it's fairly
draw I would state but I feel like both
players can absolutely find some lines
in here to give their opponents
something to think about at least but in
the game 34 moves and we have a draw so
fairly disappointing I think Magnus
Carlsen even afterwards said I was
disappointing for him he felt like he's
been getting out prepared by Fabiano
especially when Fabiano has the black
pieces Carson said he needs to play
better he needs to start getting some
win especially when he has the white
pieces has not done so so far so four
games in we have four draws we will have
a rest date tomorrow hoping that both
sides can get some well-deserved rest
but also work with their teams and see
if they can find some unique lines that
the players haven't seen really what
comes out of that is lots of time early
on as players are just thinking about
the situation that tends to later on in
the game less time for them to think
lots of crazy
you know things can happen on the board
whether that's errors are just lines
where there's four or five different
variations after really think about it
that should I think get us a victory in
the near term but we will see thank you
guys so much for watching hopefully you
enjoying the tournament and I'll see you
in two days for game number five